Hey Youtubers, we are Groot.
A lot of you are asking me about the guardians
characters that are going to be in infinity
war there were some new confirmations so this
is going to be a breakdown, there's a whole
bunch of Guardians stuff that's going to be
happening in the next couple weeks they're
going to start their official marketing campaign
for the movie.
So you will start saying a whole bunch of
stuff they started teasing all the toys and
stuff, so I'll be doing some fun giveaways
for now new round of the Spider-Man giveaway.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
It's a $20 comixology giftcard, so I'm going
to start with the really big characters and
work my way down through the new ones too
mostly focusing on the new ones because their
lot of new people in this film we haven't
seen before like mantis but they're all from
the comics the gonna be awesome just start
with mantis, so a lot of you are probably
familiar with the mantis character if you
been reading the guardians of the galaxy,
comic for a while and most of you probably
know the annihilation conquest version was
recruited by star Lord and used her abilities
to sort of hypnotize convince the other members
of the team to join up the really interesting
thing about that comic book arc in the reason
why you should probably go back and reread
it at some point is because the annihilation
conquest was all about the attack from the
phalanx upon the galaxy led by Ultron would
been fired into outer space after the mighty
avengers arc which is basically that story
line that they adapted for Avengers: Age of
Ultron.
So you have to imagine that Ultron in the
continuity right now is just hiding out somewhere
probably buried in visions programming, but
in the comics, what they did is they fired
Ultron into deep space he landed on the phalanx
and was able to take over their techno based
culture and they became this scourge on the
galaxy which inspired star Lord to put a team
together and that became the beginning of
the modern version of the guardians of the
galaxy that the classic guardians actually
had Yondu in the lineup he's going to be in
the lineup for the new movie and unfortunately
he is unconfirmed for infinity war, but I
wouldn't be surprised if he shows up he just
too unique of a character cannot get in there
somewhere, but along those lines mantis Yondu
infinity war.
Not all cameos and appearances are created
equal.
So really like the big storm guardians of
the galaxy is star Lord he's obviously going
to have a much bigger part in infinity war
than the other characters, but really the
whole main cast is going to be coming to infinity
war at least in a small way just some of them
were gonna get way more screen time than the
others like of course there's going to be
some funny group moments with the other real
avengers you can just picture.
Spider-Man and Tony Stark flipping their lives
to be the coolest thing ever.
But the really cool thing about mantis is
that in the comics she's actually a really
bad ass fighter.
She's almost like Karnak with the way she
can sense weaknesses and use those as exploits
during fight.
So that's how she can fight someone big like
Drax, but in the context of the movie her
character just a little different, so what
James Gunn did is he took the more modern
version of the character and sort of gave
her the look of the classic mantis and then
weaved her back story in with star Lord, so
she's like the half-sister of star Lord with
ego the living planet is crazy is all that
sounds she's just as much of a bad ass is
most of the other avengers characters.
There were a couple moments when she faced,
then those clones people think she's as powerful
as Thor, but I feel like they simplify things
a little bit for the MCU movies so Thor is
always going to be like the big tough guy,
but in the way they play of those funny moments.
There's a lot of tough guys on the guardians
like Gamora is a tough guy Drax is a tough
guy they'll be all kinds a bad ass jokes when
they meet up on screen and a lot of people
are wondering about, Nathan Filion's character
he's playing Simon Williams a.k.a.
wonder man in guardians of the galaxy.
So the thing is is the way they're playing
it in the movie is that it's sort of like
an Easter egg like he's an actor he's not
the actual wonder man from the comics with
wonder man's powers, he just somebody you
as the name and it's gonna be really funny
thing for fans who know who the wonder man
character is so they haven't said anything
about including him during infinity war, but
I do think that they will include a small,
Nathan Filion Easter egg probably not a speaking
role, but you see this poster in the background
here expect something like this.
So technically he would be part of infinity
war without actually having a speaking role
in that's going to be true of a lot of the
lesser characters you will we talk about characters
being infinity war.
Just remember that they have like 66+ characters
that they teased most of those will not be
speaking role still be names on list of the
people that you see in the background there
can be very few people that actually speak
on camera and you see in the foreground next
big one is nebula Karen Gillan actually tease
that she was going to be part of infinity
war, but she said it would be a very big thing,
so you just have to remember that she is one
of the daughters of Thanos, so that sort of
justifies her presence in the film she's really
big in the guardians movie she's even going
to be traveling with them for little while.
So the be a lot of crazy Gamora nebula sister
stuff going on to the gonna carry that into
infinity war but the other big surprise is
that crackling Sean guns character James Gunn's
brother is going to be in infinity war, which
is means of there's gonna be a ravage her
stuff going on that almost confirms that the
gonna do Yondu because why would you do a
much lesser character from the ravage her's
without doing him everyone's asking about
Sylvester Stallone's character I think he's
just going to be in guardians and really it
just sort of like a wink at the fans the role
that he plays it's gonna be a lot of fun but
I think is just a one-off thing the nova Corps
will crossover a little they haven't confirmed
Glenn close.
I think it's more likely that they would include
Jon C Riley because they have the power stone
right now.
So because Thanos does not have that and he's
not appearing during guardians of the galaxy
to does have to address how he gets the power
stone.
That's where the nova Corps comes in with
deep cut collector very important character
that's not going to be in guardians to has
to come back for infinity war because he has
the reality gem still they gave to them at
the end of Thor the dark world which is sort
of the connective tissue between the other
films so at the end of guardians to the expected
Post credit scene is going to be Thor Ragnarok
just because that's the next movie that's
coming.
There was a guardians Post credit scene at
the end of the last Thor movie can assure
will be absolutely safe in my life one though.
So it just makes sense that the two space-based
Marvel movies have little connective tissue
between them because they both dealt with
really cosmic threads infinity stones.
So all that remains is what tease the Thor
Ragnarok, we can talk about that after we
see guardians because it's actually coming
in a couple months but the really big character
that everyone is talking about.
That's probably not going to show up during
infinity war is ego the living planet Kurt
Russell's character he's not expected for
infinity war.
Whatever his arc is going to be it's gonna
close with guardians to, I don't think they'll
kill them off.
The way James Gunn said that he's engineered
his story is that it's still very self-contained
like he doesn't have to connect to the other
films that's really what the post credits
scenes are for what about the actual crossover
like why would the guardians ever need to
meet with the people on earth will really
it has to do with star Lord learning about
threats to the earth his home, so him being
pulled back there.
That way, the biggest threat would be Thanos
with the gem.
So the simplest idea would be for them to
have some sort of moment with the as guardians
or somebody else from the avengers really
Thor's the easiest character because he's
the only one that anybody from the guardians
movies has actually met, so they begin their
infinity quest to stop Thanos from completing
his mission that throws them into the path
of the other Earth-based avengers.
So really I think we'll see a guardians Thor
crossover, before we actually see and interact
with any of the other Earth-based avengers.
So if your friends ask you which guardians
are going to show up during infinity war you
could almost say all of them but just remember
that there's going to be like 2 1/2 hours
a movie will probably see a lot of those guardians
characters in less than 10 minutes of that
the people you see on screen, most of the
time will be like star Lord Gamora group rocket
you get the idea the biggest characters will
get the most screen time in the same is true
from the other franchises the be other Thor
characters that will crossover with infinity
war.
Some of them will only show very briefly some
of them like Thor himself Valkyrie will get
way more screen time, let me know what you
guys most excited for in guardians to, I know
everybody wants to know about ego the living
planet.
There's so many mind-boggling possibilities
just explaining the way that he was able to
fashion himself a human body so that he could
have a child with the human woman but just
reminder that Disney supposed to be promoting
guardians of the galaxy in the new Pirates
movie during the Super Bowl.
So whenever they drop new footage I will totally
do a video for it.
So it's gonna be awesome and there will be
a whole bunch of other Super Bowl trailer
videos that I'll do what you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to rewatch
the guardians trailer again and you can click
here to learn about what's going on with Black
Panther they started film thank you so much
watching everybody high five I'll see the
next video!